madame lu monsieur le ministre je suis
heureuse de vous entendre dire que les
excédents de l'agir Carco sont liés à
des sacrifices qui ont été consentis par
les salariés du secteur privé de ce pays
qui à partir de la génération
1957 ont accepté une baisse de 10 % du
montant de leur retraite complémentaire
pour enflouer les caisses de l'agir
Carco c'est à la suite de cette
génération de 1957 la génération qui
arrive et qui devait prendre sa retraite
se voit obligé de travailler de 3 à 2
ans de plus et c'est grâce à cela nous
dites-vous que les les les réserves de
laagcco vont encore s'améliorer et que
donc il faudrait qu'elles soit utilisée
pour combler un éventuel déficit des
retraite autrement dit les salariés dans
ce pays sont ceux qui font tous les
sacrifices ce sont ceux qui acceptent de
payer de de percevoir moins de
retraite qui accepte de travailler plus
longtemps ce sont ceux à qui on ne peut
absolument pas proposer au moins un
grand débat dans ce pays sur les
salaires les salariés sont décidément la
force vive de ce pays et pourtant une
force vive de ce pays que ce
gouvernement n'a pas l'air de beaucoup
aimer j'en veux pour preuve les propos
du ministre des relation avec le
Parlement qui a osé
fustiger ces irresponsables de
partenaires sociaux le mot n'a pas été
prononcé mais il était bien entendu
sous-entendu qui allait dépenser leur
argent plutôt que de le donner au
gouvernement pour combler le déficit
qu'il n'est pas capable de combler par
ailleurs faut conclure
merci